hey guys this is Pete peppers and this
is a couple people who are having
problems understanding how the point
then and the jellyfish works and scrubby
w saugus so this is a scrubby dubby saga
level 83 commentary walkthrough with
tips on how to do that in the original
version of the game you know these
plankton jellyfish levels came out
earlier so they come on in round level
80 now and they get pretty tough right
away so might be a reason why people
have a trouble of getting the idea but
basically what we have here is we have a
jellyfish at the top left corner and
then we have some plankton in the top
right corner corner and we need to
spread it from the plankton from the
right side to the left side to feed the
jellyfish to collect so I'm going to go
ahead and do that you can see that by
making this match with the purple that
will get that that plankton spread
downward and then we need to also remove
the sand castles as we go along the
blockers in the middle so we're just
going to do a little bit of both spread
the plankton while we can but make make
space at the same time this is um this
is one of those levels you might need to
get a pretty good board to get past this
one because you know it's really small
areas but I'll take your time you can
usually find something that will help
and you can see there that the plankton
has moved down even more we got most of
the most of our most of the stuff out of
the way in the middle and we do have
timers here too they're going to spread
some ice so we want to keep an eye on
that we don't want that to get like in
front of the path I guess would be the
way to explain it but we can we don't
have to worry about any of that are back
on the right hand side right now because
we'll be able to the plankton is out
ahead of it so we can still spread it
here there's a choice I can make I can
get rid of this timer with the one get
it out of the way or I can make
screen match on the left I think I like
making that one better to keep that we
have seven moves so we have plenty of
time and this special we would have
created wouldn't have made a big
difference anyways so now I just now I
got the plankton pretty close I can make
the match I got the sand castle out of
the way I can make this match here and
now the plankton is directly underneath
and actually here we could do it two
different ways we can match the green
and that will feed the jellyfish so we
can hit the the special at the bottom
and that will spread it also because
we're 22 crossed it so it spreads it
straight up from where it was that so
that's how it works it's a little bit
frustrating trying to get to go around
the horn there whatever you want to call
it the u-shape and then you have a
little bottleneck there but take your
time plan things out and you'll get it
soon hopefully this helped please like
the video if you found it useful
subscribe to our channel or one of the
only youtube channels or we actually add
the tips right in the video so make sure
you subscribe so you see when we put new
ones out if you need help leave a
comment below and we'll be seeing you
soon thanks